welcome back to ctm
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning we're going to do something a
little different
as the world prepares to say goodbye to
one of the most difficult years we've
had in history
we asked spiritual leaders for their
thoughts on unity and hope heading into
2021.
so we spoke with imam omar suleiman
founder of the yakin institute for
islamic research
roshi pat in keo o'hara a zen buddhist
teacher father james martin a jesuit
priest and author of the book learning
to pray
reverend jackie lewis senior minister at
middle collegiate church
rabbi rick jacobs president of the union
for reform judaism
and sanjida kausik
hindu who is an advisor at new york
university
20 20 has been a terrible year and it's
not surprising that people
would sometimes feel tempted to despair
but i like to remind people that those
feelings of despair
aren't coming from god that's not the
way that god works feelings of hope are
the only thing that keeps us going is
hope and firm
faith in god that everything that
happened even the losses that you have
suffered
is for a reason
the quran says that with every hardship
there is ease
and so when blessings are taken away
from us voluntarily or involuntarily
then we have a greater awareness of god
a greater awareness of self and a
greater awareness of other
and that's where we seek the greatest
growth
so my hope comes from the human will to
survive the tenacity and resilience of
human beings
in partnership with a holy other which
is how i think about god as a holy other
and in partnership together we make it
we just do
we rise up out of ashes and we talk
about it and we do new things together
love thy neighbor is one of those great
teachings in the hebrew bible
but it only is mentioned once love the
strangers mentioned 36 times why because
it's much
harder and as a buddhist what's
important to me is that we
recognize that we are interconnected
loving the stranger loving the one who's
different
that's where we anchor our lives on a
very different foundation and that's how
we overcome
the incredibly painful divisions of this
moment
listen with compassion realize
that on a fundamental level as two
humans
the person who thinks completely
differently than i do
is another human that we have that
connection and maybe
maybe it's just expressing a little
empathy but it's the beginning of a
bridge
rather than throwing a rock
i think one thing that we can all agree
on is the
the valor um and the heroism of our
health care professionals the example
that we've been given
by the caring people particularly in the
essentially the essential workers
you know the people that are running the
subways around here
as well as as the ones that are in
medical
frame those are our heroes sometimes in
our darkest moments we find our greatest
unity and
the greatest beauty in that unity comes
in the midst of that darkness
we know how to have our neighbors backs
we know how to
put sandbags along each other's houses
we know how to give each other groceries
and take care of each other's kids we do
know how to do it if we talk
more about what we have in common and
emphasize what we have in common i think
goodness
triumphs over evil every single time the
light triumphs over
darkness every single time so i would
hope that as we're finishing
2020 and saying good ribbons
that we enter 21 with the feeling of
each of us is responsible for shaping 21
to be
a year of healing a year of hope
a year of kindness but that we come
together
with a shared sense of building a more
just and compassionate world
[Music]
my fondest hope for 2021 as a vaccine
let's just be blunt
that's my biggest hope and that's what
i've been praying for i hope people can
have fun again
i think just to be able to be outside
and be with your friends and
hug one another i think everybody is in
need of fun
in 2021. as we turn our faces toward a
new year
i hope that you can feel
the wind of a spirit at your back
and that your face will turn up toward
the sun and you will
imagine all of the wounds of this year
as places in which strength will grow
that we will be better
tomorrow
[Music]
what are your wishes my wishes and i
think i mentioned this yesterday is that
i hope that what we've learned about the
importance of being connected to one
another to staying in touch with your
friends and family
more than we usually do that we we
really did that this year i did that
this year
i want that to continue past 2021 for
years to come
david um my my hope is for empathy you
know people say happy new year i wish
you health and wealth and
it's for empathy because i think empathy
is what drives
the best in all of us it's important to
have empathy and i i love what
uh imam omar suleiman said in our
darkest moments we find
our greatest unity that message
resonates always with me when things are
dark it's always darkest before the dawn
it's an important moment that piece was
produced by andy murlis and sergeant
josephson
really really wonderful we'll be right
back